so uh you've asked us a lot of questions
on the channel and we figured it was
timely on to them about downtime alright
yeah
oh they write it so the most frequently
asked question is that top one there
yeah okay
what is it it's a what software do you
use to make the slow motion that's a
very easy question to answer none we
don't use any software it's all done in
camera alright what kind of use we use a
phantom flex which is this and it shoots
at 2500 frames per second in Full HD
meaty yeah Riaan it so uh how's that
custom well I won't say the exact price
but let's say you could get a very
lovely Aston Martin db9 for the cost of
that and your four dozen well I don't
but I do work with these cameras we've
got two of them
and we work on like music videos and
commercials and movies and stuff like
that but obviously when we're not
working
might as well whip them out and do a bit
slow mo guys whip them out yeah what do
you use to edit edit the videos together
all the slow mo guys episodes edited on
a Mac Pro and using Final Cut this is an
average timeline for one of the videos
you can see there's quite a lot of sound
here because the camera doesn't actually
record any sound at all so I have got
I've got take it from the real-time
footage or just add sound effects do you
need a lot of hard drives
let's see yeah sir one two that's two
times it's four to ice in there six
total but 15 yes yes you doing it yes
okay this thing when it's going full
speed will shoot eight gigs per second
which really a really test through the
old hard drives bit so yeah the actual
camera records onto these things which
is very high-speed flash storage
and I just clip on there what would you
say the biggest the biggest request has
been for us to film paintball guns
paintball guns yes surprising I didn't
think yeah many people want to see
people dance but I'm sure we can get
hold of a paintball gun and yes just do
it you can send a requests yeah type
what you want us to film we'll probably
get around to doing it and we can do
ridiculous question arts videos as well
yeah that's a stupid question
yeah please take a paintball to the
drive lady topless imagine so yeah oh
the audience would dig that yeah
apparently Andrew
you've been named and shamed there now
this is something that many people get
confused about is why it's called a high
speed camera but it's actually filming
in slow motion so Dan take it away with
the extremely science II and nerdy
answer go alright um you got a normal
camera it takes a certain amount of
frames per second for instance you've
got 25 frames a second which means that
something that's happening a very high
speed like my hand doing that okay then
if you had a camera that yeah that's
pretty fast yeah if you had a camera
that did say 25 frames a second you get
one frame here one from here one frame
here so you would only see three images
but with a with a high-speed camera it
takes a lot of frames per second and
that means that you get many more frames
like this and so you get to see it much
clearer and that's how you get the slow
motion because you get a more solid
movement before obviously when you've
got 25 frames you're taking a picture
every 25th and a second if you've got
something that's moving faster than that
you need more frames in between which is
why if I take 2,500 frames in a second
and then play it back with 25 frames it
would last a hundred seconds instead of
one second and that's why high speed is
slow motion
another very frequently asked question
what music do you use over the slow-mo
bits yeah
every one that's the most common else of
course ask cristen actually I don't want
it to be silent in the slo-mo bits
because you can put sound effect in but
there might be a big gap between that
and the next sound effect so I just
trying to find some sort
of a bit of you know kind of mesmerizing
sound yeah I don't know what I'm doing
no but um it was actually just some
random sound effect that comes with high
life on the Mac you know get that big
sound effects photo from iMovie and
stuff and I think what it is it's like a
little chorus of people going ah
and I just slowed it down so it's like
ooh it's called synthetic design - from
this sound effect folder and it sounds
like
yeah buddy slowed down it sounds like
this
why do you run away sometimes after
doing some of the clips I mean so it's
the first that you've hit them in in the
face with the football and then ran away
why I was scared that you'd hit me I'm
not sure people have actually noticed I
sort of run away after the event happens
it's not cuz I'm scared it's because
this camera actually records backwards
in time so what actually doing is
stopping the camera and then it saves
the previous four seconds of time and
yet basics me just pressing record is
loyd the cat declawed no we don't
declawed cats I'm not sure so I so know
people are interested it's like a
human's getting their nails removed
completely something I think they remove
a nook or something yeah it's a very
much frowned upon in the UK so no it's
it's a cat with claws and the scars
um are you Gavin from UT yes yes I am
yeah yeah so red versus blue yeah love
it
hey I just had this really weird
conversation with Gus yeah he's probably
hitting on you wouldn't be offended by
that was bound to happen eventually so
why the hell do people keep mentioning
headlight fluid in your comments it's
kind of a kind of touchy subject I'm
just going to say listen to the drunk
tank
it's the roosterteeth podcast you can
find on iTunes it's amazing I used to be
on it
why have some videos slower than others
yeah we had this ask because there's
some where we shot a thousand frames
like the light bulb smashing and they're
like one issue that bit slower would
have been nice to see in a bit more
detail err and that's cuz we didn't have
this camera that that was actually shot
on the phantom HD gold and this is the
Phantom flex so basically all of these
videos were shot on the previous camera
yeah and all the others were shot with
this basically if you lower the
resolution of these cameras so it's
taking a smaller image it can take more
every second so a 720p can do five
thousand and if you lower it all the way
down to something like you know postage
stamp-sized I'll do two hundred and
eighty thousand frames a second and at
that point you're slowing one second
down to a few hours which is extremely
slow
and do you guys play video games no no
never
hey um yeah
geeks what's your game attack it must be
joking right that's pretty much all the
questions that I've selected you can
obviously keep asking more but they're
the main ones that we've answered now
yeah pretty shuttle II I thought but
general idea all right
q fake video game acting good